pour le 25 mai la commission européenne
promet le changement le plus important
en matière de confidentialité des
données depuis vingt ans les gens auront
le droit de dire oui ou non dès qu'il
s'agit d'utiliser leurs données le
nouveau règlement général de protection
des données c'est son nom oblige les
entreprises à révéler quelles données
personnelles sont collectées comment
elles sont utilisées et de quelle
manière elles sont sécurisés ce
règlement garantie des droits précis aux
citoyens un site ou un service en ligne
qui veut utiliser nos données devra
obtenir notre accord écrit un enfant ne
pourra pas s'inscrire sur un réseau
social sans l'accord des parents
l'internaute dispose d'un droit à
l'oubli pour faire disparaître ces
données personnelles et enfin nous
pourrons être défendus par des
associations dans le cadre d'une action
de groupe mais plusieurs obstacles
risquent de freiner la mise en oeuvre de
ces protections
ainsi le règlement réduit l'usagé des
cookies qui espionnent les consommateurs
mais paradoxalement cela favorise les
entreprises qui n'utilisent pas ces
cookies mais piste directement les
identités des internautes et ce sera
tout bénéfice pour les gaffes à les
apple amazon et autres qui contournent
ainsi le règlement seront aussi
favoriser les acteurs mondiaux qui
fournissent des services gratuits aux
consommateurs on pense à google ou
facebook qui obtiennent plus facilement
le droit d'utiliser les données des
internautes qu'un quelconque site de
vente en ligne
un autre maillon faible de la protection
des données et l'impréparation des
entreprises
60% d'entre elles risquent tout
simplement de ne pas être prête pour le
tuez les maillons faibles au revoir
ainsi plus de la moitié des applications
du magasin en ligne les store de google
ne sont pas conformes aux règlements et
enfin où en sont les législations
nationales
à ce jour seuls trois pays sont
conformes à la réglementation l'autriche
l'allemagne et la slovaquie
alors le données seront elles mieux
protéger le 25 mai prochain
c'est partiellement vrai